for the children in the northern Iraq
camp of de paga this visitor is a
welcome distraction from the daily camp
routine but for their parents and
grandparents crystal silly Anita's the
EU commissioner for humanitarian aid is
someone who embodies hope and you
satisfied from this existence in Merida
Initiative well ain't it oh I am I
couldn't get most of the services here
and there's a very long roll the camp
largely financed by the EU is
overcrowded providing shelter to some
27,000 people but more coming every day
from around Iraq second-largest city
Mosul still controlled by the so-called
Islamic state up to 1 million people
could be forced to flee their homes as
fighting intensifies it's very emotional
and of course it's very painful for us
to see the situation on the ground and
to feel the suffering of you know we
give these people hope and dignity that
has a high price here it seems the
Commissioner is told if the camp were to
be expanded it could cost up to 1
million euros in rent for the
surrounding private land so are you guys
gonna pay as the government gonna pay
but the Kurdish response is no the new
arrivals are already expensive enough to
deal with many have lived under is rule
for years and have to be screened before
entering the camp we have some
experience one month ago when family was
fleeing one of them he suicide himself
and tell people was injured one reason
the security for the Commissioner is
very high but so far his ambitions we
can make a difference Iraq
dash will be defeated on the battlefield
but we must also defeat their poisons
ideology and narrative this is maybe
more difficult stiliyan EDA's is
visiting iraq for the third time at
temperatures around 50 degrees Celsius
the landscape has dried up as has the
budget of the Kurdish regional
government in air bill I'm told
president Masoud Barzani is concerned
about the low oil prices and the cost of
fighting is the mission st glee anita's
has one meeting after the other lined up
here in a bell and the message he gets
is almost always the same the Autonomous
Region in the north of Iraq needs more
help from the European Union the
Commissioner is told that providing for
more refugees would be beyond Kurdish
capabilities politicians here are well
aware of the kind of leverage they have
if they can provide their needs here
they would not be coming to your
doorstep as asylum seekers so the
migration will continue to Europe unless
we try to address the root causes of the
problem wire here still I anita's has
already increased the humanitarian aid
for Iraq by 194 million euros but he
knows it's not enough he needs our show
so huge and is something beyond how our
abilities in our capacity capacities
capacity to meet these needs and this is
why I strongly believe that we need to
have we need global answer if the
liberation of muscle starts without that
answer Stiliyan Edith warns Iraq could
face yet another humanitarian
catastrophe